JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
You've been learning in
lecture about matrices
and their various
applications, and one of them
is to solving systems
of linear equations.
So I have here a system of
three linear equations for you.
2x plus c*z equals 4, x
minus y plus 2z equals pi,
and x minus 2y plus
2z equals minus 12.
So what I'd like you
to do is the following.
Find the value of c--
or all values of c--
for which, first of all,
there's a unique solution
to this system.
Second of all, for which the
corresponding homogeneous
system has a unique solution.
So remember that the
corresponding homogeneous
system is the system where you
just replace these constants
on the right by 0.
So it's a very
similar-looking system.
The left-hand sides
are all the same,
but the right-hand sides
are replaced with 0.
So you want to find the value
of c for which this system has
a unique solution,
the value of c
for which the corresponding
homogeneous system has
a unique solution, and
also the values of c
for which the corresponding
homogeneous system has
infinitely many solutions.
Note that I'm not asking you to
solve this system of equations,
although you're welcome
to do so if you like.
Although, of course,
whether you can or not
might depend on the value of c.
So why don't you pause the
video, take a little while
to work out the solutions
to these three questions,
come back, and we can
work it out together.
So hopefully you have some luck
working out these problems.
Let's start working
through them together.
So I'm actually going
to take parts a and b
together at the same time.
And the reason that
I'm going to do
that is that one
thing you've learned
is that a system has
a unique solution for,
on the right-hand side-- sorry--
a system has a unique solution,
like this, a square
system of linear equations
has a unique
solution if and only
if it has a unique
solution regardless
of what the right-hand side is.
So in particular, the answer
to a and the answer to b
are exactly the same.
So values of c for which this
system has a unique solution
are exactly the same as values
of c for which the homogeneous
system has a unique solution.
Now the solutions will
be different, of course.
But the value of
c-- or the values
of c-- that make it
solvable uniquely,
make it solvable uniquely
for all right-hand sides.
And so which values
of c are those?
Well, those are the
values of c for which
the coefficient matrix on the
left-hand side is invertible.
So if the coefficient
matrix on the left-hand side
is invertible, then we
can solve this system
and we get a unique solution.
If it's not invertible,
then either we
can't solve this system--
like, there are no solutions--
or we can solve this system,
but there are infinitely
many solutions.
So in both questions
a and b, we're
asking for the value of c for
which the coefficient matrix
of the left-hand
side is invertible,
and that will be when we
have a unique solution.
So how do we know when
a matrix is invertible?
Well, let's write down what
the matrix is first of all.
So this matrix M that we're
after is equal to the matrix
2, 0, c; 1, minus
1, 2; 1, minus 2, 2.
So this is the coefficient
matrix M of that system,
and we want to know for which
values of c is it invertible.
Well, when is a
matrix invertible?
A matrix is invertible--
square matrix is invertible--
precisely when it has
non-zero determinant.
So we just need to look at the
determinant of this matrix.
So you've learned how to compute
determinants of matrices,
I think.
So let's, in this case,
we have the det M.
So it's a sum or difference
of six different terms,
and you could get
it, for example,
by the Laplace expansion
if you wanted to.
So I'm just going to write
out what the six terms are.
So it's 2 times minus 1 times
2, plus 0 times 2 times 1,
plus c times 1 times minus
2, minus c times minus 1
times 1, minus 2 times minus 2
times 2, minus 0 times 1 times
2.
So this is the determinant
of this matrix.
You can get it either
just by remembering
which terms are which
and which get a plus sign
and which get a minus sign, or
by doing the Laplace expansion,
or by whatever other tricks
you might happen to know.
So now we need to know whether
or not this determinant is 0.
So let's work out what this is.
So this is-- let me
start simplifying it.
So this is minus 4
plus 0 minus 2c--
this is minus minus
c, so plus c--
this is minus minus 8, so plus
8, which is equal to 4 minus c.
So the determinant--
right, two of those terms
are 0, and so I just
get to leave them out.
So the determinant of
this matrix is 4 minus c.
And what we're
interested in is when
this determinant is non-zero.
So in particular, for c
not equal to 0-- sorry,
for c not equal to 4-- when c
is not 4, the determinant of M
is not 0.
So when c is not 4,
determinant of M is not 0,
so both systems-- both
the original system
and the corresponding
homogeneous system--
have a unique solution.
So when c is not 4-- so
for most values of c--
the determinant is
not 0, and the system
has a unique solution.
So when c is equal
to 4, what happens?
Well, when c is equal to 4,
we're in the bottom case.
We're in the case where
the homogeneous system has
infinitely many solutions.
OK?
So let me write that over here.
When c equals 4-- I'm
going to abbreviate
again-- the homogeneous
system has-- I'm
going to use this symbol-- this
sort of sideways eight symbol
means infinity, so
I'm going to use it
for infinitely many solutions.
So when c is 4, the
homogeneous system
has infinitely many solutions.
And you might be
curious-- well, so let
me say one more
thing about that.
We know when the coefficient
matrix isn't invertible
that the system either has zero
or infinitely many solutions.
But the homogeneous system
always has a solution.
It always has the solution
where everything is all 0.
Right?
So that's why we know that
it's infinitely many here.
And one thing you might ask
is can you find any others?
Can you find any solutions
that aren't just [0, 0, 0]?
And the answer is yes.
So this is now going beyond
when I asked you to do,
but I think it's, you know,
an interesting thing to see.
So if you wanted to find another
solution, what do you know?
Well, let's go back to
the equations that we had.
So when we're dealing
with a homogeneous system,
the right-hand sides are 0.
So I'm just going to cross
out these right-hand sides
and replace them with 0
so we don't get confused.
So this is 0, 0, and 0.
So we're dealing with this
system: 2x plus c*z equals 0,
x minus y plus 2z equals 0, and
x minus 2y plus 2z equals 0.
OK, so if you want
a solution [x, y, z]
to this system,
what do you know?
Well, from the second equation,
you know that the vector
[x, y, z] is orthogonal to
the vector 1, minus 1, 2.
How do you know that?
Because this left-hand
side, x minus y plus 2z,
is equal to [x, y, z]
dot 1, minus 1, 2.
And similarly from
the third equation,
you know that the
vector [x, y,  z]
is orthogonal to the
vector 1, minus 2, 2,
because this left-hand side
is equal to [x, y, z] dot 1,
minus 2, 2.
Yeah?
And that's equal to 0.
So from the second
and third equations,
you know that you're
looking for a vector that's
orthogonal to both
x-- or sorry-- both 1,
minus 1, 2, and 1, minus 2, 2.
How do you get a
vector perpendicular
to two known vectors?
Well, you just take
their cross product.
So let's go back over here.
So to find one, you
take a cross product
of two rows of the
coefficient matrix.
So in this case, for example,
we can take these rows, 1,
minus 1, 2; and 1, minus 2, 2.
So, for example, the
vector 1, minus 1,
2-- OK-- cross the
vector 1, minus 2, 2.
Now I've kind of run
out of board space,
so I'm not going to work out
precisely what this vector is
for you.
But if you like, you
can certainly check.
You can compute this
cross product out
with our nice formula
for the cross product.
It will give you some
vector, and then you
can check that that
vector is indeed
a solution of the
homogeneous system.
So that will give
us a second solution
of the homogeneous system.
Nontrivial we say, because
it's not just the 0 solution.
So to quickly recap, we had
a system of linear equations.
I've now crossed out what the
original right-hand side was.
We had a system of
linear equations,
and we were looking for a choice
of c for which that system had
a unique solution and for which
the corresponding homogeneous
system had a unique solution.
And the values of c that
make that work are precisely
the values of c such that
the coefficient matrix
has a non-zero determinant.
So that's true for
both parts a and b.
And for part c, when we were
looking for what values of c
give the homogeneous system
infinitely many solutions,
the answer is any
other value of c.
Any value of c for which
the coefficient matrix does
have 0 determinant will give
you infinitely many solutions
in the homogeneous case,
and in non-homogeneous cases
will either give you 0 solutions
or infinitely many solutions.
And then we also at
the end, we briefly
discussed one way to
find nontrivial solutions
in the homogeneous case
when there are infinitely
many solutions.
So I'll end there.